before you decide to take off your hijab
ask yourself this
so another hijab' influencer removes her
hijab and social media platforms go into
a complete frenzy with people quickly
jumping to take sides
some condemning others supporting and
some just therefore the comments and
look let me be the first to admit that
wearing the hijab is not the easiest
thing to pull off in 2020 the high job
is a caped Muslim women wear publicly
day in and day out and it comes with a
whole lot of hardships
Liat not getting that job who really
wanted beat the racial slurs or in my
case being called the letterbox thanks
Boris and this isn't even to mention the
social pressures of trying to look our
best in a world of glamorous
photoshopped imagery of women as high
Chevys we're constantly fighting this
uphill battle of self-consciousness and
doubt and we live with it daily but
before we get too carried away in all
the struggles the real question we
should be asking ourselves is have we
lost the conviction as to why we are
wearing the hijab in the first place in
Islam the hijab is more than just the
garment to cover our hair it is a form
of modesty that Islam demands from both
men and women hey Jeff symbolizes the
true meaning of obeying a law and
encompasses modest character behavior
and manners
now after understanding that the hijab
is an obligation from God we can see how
this will be viewed as problematic in
today's modern world a world that
celebrates the liberation of the
individual and the ego made me a world
that teaches you to focus on yourself to
love yourself unconditionally and to put
yourself first
and while self-care and self-love are no
doubt important we have to be very
careful it doesn't turn into self
worship whereby we no longer worship God
but rather our own egos and with the
current ego boosting social media
platforms one can easily lose the real
meaning of the hijab transforming it
from being an avenue of obeying a law to
becoming just another trendy form of
social expression that changes with the
latest hashtag and this is exactly why
we are seeing
so many public figures who have a huge
platform take off their hijab because
they say they are speaking their truth
so now post-high Chevy's coming out as a
narrative welcomed with praise and
admiration for being ones authentic self
such a phrase poses some dangerous
implications especially when your truth
is at odds with a Las truth as allah
says in the quran it is not for a
believer a man or women when allah and
his messenger have decreed a matter that
they should have any option in their
decision another statement that is
gaining traction online is the old
phrase only god can judge me and while
no one is commenting on other state of
amman it is important to point out that
these influencers are in fact
influencing many of our sisters today
even if these heavy influencers never
claimed to be role models having such a
huge platform comes with great
responsibility that we will be held
accountable for so where do we go from
here as a fellow muslim sister i
understand the struggle and honestly we
all need to help and support each other
to get through today's challenges but if
you do feel the pressure here's a few
things we should remember first and
foremost always surround yourself with a
positive environment that fortifies your
amen surround yourself with sisters who
elevate you and are there for you when
you hit that amman low make time to
attend lessons at your local mosque and
if there aren't any programs take
initiative control your social media
feed so you're not constantly subjected
to content that makes you feel bad about
yourself learn the stories of the great
women like Miriam Asiya Khadija and
Fatima read the stories of the female
companions of the Prophet sallallahu
wasallam
to remind ourselves of what it really
means to be close to Allah and remember
no one is immune to tribulations in
their faith and that is why it is
important that we constantly make duaa
to Allah to give us the strength and
perseverance through all the challenges
that come our way as the prophet
sallallaahu Lam Taurus llamo Kali BALCO
Lube Sabbath kalbi eyelid Enoch or
controller of the hearts keep our hearts
steadfast
and if you do know anyone struggling
don't put them down rather lift them up
and see how you can help them so for all
our sisters out there at a crossroad
before you decide to take off your hijab
ask yourself this are you praying your
daily Salah is your environment
cultivating your Amen and how is your
relationship with Allah Spinal tada we
are all in this together and I pray that
Allah gives us the strength to stay
strong in our faith amidst all the
struggles Allah bless you all
the reality is Islamophobia and negative
portrayal of Muslims in the media is an
industry that continues to thrive and
there are so many around the world who
still don't have access to genuine
Islamic content so as much as we would
love to celebrate our achievements the
reality is we have so much more work to
do while the grace of allah subhanahu
wata'ala we have had tremendous success
and we cannot express how valuable the
community support has been in making all
this happen we invite you to continue
this journey with us
one path they work everyone's invited
[Music]